découvrez-en icinéma no way out
je suis désolé mais une greffe de rein
est la seule solution c'est coûte
presque 200 ans j'ai repris mon ancien
boulot j'ai pas envie que tu peux pas
prendre tout ce que je veux faire c'est
protéger est revenu me voir
j'en étais super talent et jetant des
bouts le camion transporte des balles de
golf
bourré de drogue qui voit le camion est
une la loi
et elle a plus besoin de produire
c'est dangereux c'est quoi cette
question à la crampe
je me pose la question quel est
l'instance et qui a bien pu faire ça je
vous ait sous-estimé mon ami
j'ai quelque chose à quoi fonctionner
ouais
la mêlée pas ça quand on veut me prendre
ce qui m'appartient des innocents
connaissent une mort violente et
parfaitement inutile au vent juliette
je viens chercher juliette
cours petit lapin cours tu es en retard
et l'école moment encore
tous ses problèmes toute cette
souffrance par amour
[Musique]
no way out le 24 mai sur au service de
vidéo à la demande
exclusivement chez vous